so continuing with educational pride  month content  how about we take a quick look at the  term trans  and specifically the fact that trans is  meant to be an umbrella term  i know for a lot of people in their  minds it means one fairly specific thing  transitioning from the gender sign at  birth to the opposing gender  viewing gender as a binary but it's a  bit more complicated than that well  it is and it isn't it encompasses a lot  more than that but it's actually not all  that complicated now  a trans man is someone who was assigned  female at birth and now identifies and  is a man a trans woman  it was assigned male at birth and now  identifies and is a woman  but those are not the only sorts of  trans there is strictly speaking all  trans means  is that the person does not identify as  the gender assigned at birth  and because people aren't assigned  gender fluid  non-binary agender or any number of  other things  those fall under the trans umbrella too